so smp global really has basically five
business lines now there's a rating
agency
there's the s p 500 and the dow jones
index business
there's platts which is an energy focus
basically side of the
company like a lot of research around
[Music]
fracking and oils
and
market intelligence which is basically
kind of like a data analytics vendor
and then the fifth one is relatively new
it's called sustainable one it's
completely an organization focused
around esg data and finance
so in that area i run the
new product development so i'm
technically under the product management
group
so i leverage a lot of the technology
folks in data science
a lot of the folks in what we call
content which is like automation teams
that do more rpa work and of course my
own team which is technically
generally more quantitative but in a
a more uh
user-oriented fashion i should say so
one you know when we say when i'm
talking about new products for smp it's
typically products that take about six
months to a year to go to market
uh so they're not like
feature enhancements or things like that
that are like much more
transformational so so for example we've
launched
a financial statement extraction system
that basically take a document that's
completely sitting on your desktop and
then you upload it and it becomes part
of our platform
um our sentiment analytics seems for
chinese companies in the native language
and simplified chinese so things like
that that are
not typically what you might necessarily
associate with
with the smps sort of product offerings
um
so yeah we use a lot of you know we have
our production
we also use
of course a lot of the nlp tools in
python
um so we we come across all the
all the usual buzzwords in the data
science world so
hopefully that gives you an idea yeah
that's great thank you moody
i am i see rahul you asked if there was
a
slack channel um i was just mentioning
to our internal team just to share the
link to the slido
no we don't have we don't have one yet
maybe someday
but also just wanted to point out
because i didn't say in the beginning
and i realized the recording was paused
but we are recording the session as well
so
um we can share it up to youtube after
so
if any you want to share it with anyone
who missed it as well
and that link that they put into the
chat is the slido link so if
you maybe didn't want your question to
be in a recording or anything you could
ask anonymous questions as well but
love to have people jump in so if
there's certain questions that you'd
want to ask to moody as well
feel free to put those in in the chat
but moody i'd love to maybe
um get started with asking you about
some of the things that you're really
excited about in data science right now
sure i mean
yeah like
i i started kind of in the quantitative
sites about like in about two decades
now um so the exciting part i see in the
data science community is that the
ability for folks to get a lot closer to
the domains that they're working in
and i think a lot of the work that our
studio has been doing especially on like
making building applications
easy
in our actually helps sort of get that
point
across
like in my world obviously
you know in the quantitative world you
have a lot of folks who kind of just sit
behind look at numbers they don't know
what those numbers mean and how the
client will use them so
i've seen over the last at least five
years there's a lot of
a lot more transformation there where
the sort of the upcoming data scientists
actually try to think beyond the numbers
and how the clients will use them
um
and you know that's that's sort of at
least i've been in finance for a while
so in finance like you know
you get a lot of folks kind of like that
um
but yeah that's that's exciting that
that that's that's nice to like talk to
hire people who actually think already
from out of grad school like that that's
that's great right um i think more more
technical bases like
um ability to like visualize information
very easily with like very very few
lines of code like a lot of what i do on
the prototyping side
we use connect we use you know dash
but i the net result is there's very few
lines of code that you basically have to
write in order to get something that
looks like a legacy like a javascript
based basically platform
but kind of actually more cutting edge i
would say
um
and that's important
especially when you're trying to kind of
get to the last mile
because typically in bigger corporations
to build sort of those type of
applications they
you know they go on a scrum agile
release cycle takes you know quite a few
months to get to that point just to show
a client something interactive
then the other thing that excites me
third thing is i think more on the
machine learning side that you know
neural networks
obviously very very big black boxes but
they can mine a lot of data
and take advantage versus say structural
models right
explainability
side of it has become a lot more
i would say a lot easier to actually
do
um
like we use lime a lot
for model agnostic explanations like
simple things like that kind of go a
long way
to sort of like here's a nice time
series but why
like that question gets kind of answered
nicely and then ties back to the
visualization because we kind of build
things that try to simplify that answer
without having to
without having the customer to reach out
to support or to other sort of sites or
or worse cases having the quant have to
jump on a call
um you kind of want things to be more on
demand self-service and i think that
that side of it of course there's a lot
more to
still sort of
on infancy but like in the mid mid level
i think it will get easier and easier as
time goes by at least i hope so
yeah
when you think of that whole
like process and transformation the
team's taken
how did you get to
where you are now
and like what did that look like in the
beginning
um
i mean i start like you mean me
personally what my how my career kind of
progressed well you were saying like
over the past five years some of the
changes and things that have happened oh
yeah yeah i meant more like
um yeah the changes yeah i think it was
uh the reason for the changes i think
has that you know obviously a lot of the
cloud computing costs have gone down
like back in the day you'd have to have
we used to host
your own on-prem server it costs a lot
of money to actually do this so aws
has lowered that cost a lot so if
anybody can now out of the department
kind of
launch something that needs multi-gpu
multi-cpu things at relatively minimal
cost so that lowered that then the
applications i think
the the languages that are available
like r and python um
i think
python tends to be a bit more on the
software engineering side but r
especially tends to be the other way
more on the stats anal side and with our
studio you guys have done a lot of
really neat packages that made it even
easier to write code um
so i think people have
combined that computational piece with
the lower like easier to understand
or semi-functional language
and they're able to kind of get beyond
just the numbers and actually deal with
the data itself with the analysis
um i think that those two things have
kind of low made it easier for for folks
to sort of at least have an idea about
um
about what they're looking at
uh it's not i mean it's not a general
rule like you still have a lot of people
that don't
uh but i think that's that's part of it
um but yeah i mean it's very bright
future i think in that area so yeah okay
to answer your question yeah no no that
does um i don't see any questions coming
in from
anyone else yet so i'm gonna keep asking
questions if that's okay but um i know
you you spoke a little bit about some of
the visualizations that you're making on
the team whether that's in python or in
r
who do you typically share
applications out with and what does that
communication process look like yeah
yeah that makes a lot of like so to to
for me it's two sides right so
one
like internal where
and by internal folks i mean like our
sales people demoing something to a
prospect
so
we just it's a new product we're still
kind of assessing
the market appetite the addressable
market basically
um so
we build it in houses you know
comes over the vpn it's got a simple url
and connect typically
and they would go out and talk to
clients and showcase basically the
the visualizations well not really
visualization but like the workflow it's
really workflow-based tools right
and and then depending on the feedback
that's when we kind of figured out what
the best channel to put it on whether
it's a feed or it's a desktop offering
right
um that of course comes with a
powerpoint deck right
the other one which is more interesting
at least to me is that the external
piece so we have done we have we do we
have something called the incubator at
marketintelligence.com that's an
external facing
um
basically pre-prod environment if you
will it's it's we we um we can sign up
clients and prospects on it under some
you know sla type of deal and
[Music]
that is completely
whoever you sign up they go in and do
their business
using that application and that's also
serviced by in some cases connect
depending on how many users we have
concurrently
and other cases by uh like dash and
plotly
but
so that's that's kind of how we kind of
do it um
but again all of those have some
lifetime to them eventually they within
six months to a year they go back into
the platform offering which is all in
javascript
and and thinking about those i guess as
follow-up to that question i see there's
a question on slido do your clients
set standards for which tools and
approaches they need you to use or do
they just care about the end results and
you're free to choose
it depends
um
they they have standards more
not i mean not the workflow necessarily
workflow needs to be quote unquote
intuitive right so
that unfortunately goes through a lot of
like iterations right um until it
becomes interesting but like yeah yeah
depending on the product so like in like
clever analytics for example
um
you can't just basically
arbitrarily decide to build a new
network to do
you know implied rating
right because that comes with although
it's not a ratings product it is not a
ratings smp ratings product it's
lowercase letters that that goes through
a lot of audit a lot of
stability criteria
so that you can't just arbitrarily
decide and change the model like um but
yeah some of the like nlp things that i
don't think they care like we have the
text and the transcripts filings that we
have that does basically um
uh takes an earnings call converts it
into you know machine readable text like
from voice and then runs a bag of words
regularized bag of wars against it yeah
that could have also been done with a
neural network just regular respect
backwards was easier to explain
the china sentiment analytics on the
other hand is completely neural network
based right and with like model
explanation on top of it
so that we have kind of freedom for for
sort of the unregulated side of the
business right
uh
um the things that are regulated we
don't have much
on the on the visualization or the
workflow side
that's where a lot of the opinions kind
of come into play right that's
like the output means something but it's
hard for me to say upload my portfolio
and get back my output in like two
minutes you know or whatever it is right
or you know i don't really understand
why this widget kind of looks like excel
but it's not
you know so those are the things that
typically take a lot of time to sort of
convert into something easier for the
client to use but that sometimes goes
gets out of scope of the
quote-unquote mvp or a prototype piece
but you know some of it you just don't
have enough like it becomes too much
customized for connect or python to do
right so
yeah
um but you know
do they typically have some sort like do
you have a meeting with them about maybe
what the end product would look like for
them and
yeah yeah so like typically you start
with like you start with your own guests
like you because we know our client base
well enough um and we obviously they use
our desktop platforms so we take a first
step at it
we try to avoid like back in a few years
ago we were building the stuff in
balsamiq and things like that
it's less meaningful to the client so we
tend to get to the prototype something
at least functional
or fully functional like real data real
numbers room all
before we show it even to the first
friendly prospects
and then we iterate with them based on
their basic feedback and then eventually
we reach some kind of
like you know i like to say
everybody's equally unhappy you know
they're all everybody's they can get
their business done it may not be
perfect but it's it's there enough right
and that's when we kind of push it out
so that they can use it and go about it
and then collect the new feedback for
the product
side of it like for the actual legacy
platform to basically improve
um but yeah it's highly like it's a lot
of a lot of folks a lot talking directly
to the client
shifting gears a little bit i see
another question that came in uh
anonymously on slido is what is your
greatest challenge right now and how are
you tackling this
i mean right now honestly i would say
the biggest one is hiring like we need
to hire more sort of
qualified data scientists
like we obviously have a team
um we have several teams
and i think that's one of my
biggest like
uh
items to address for basically 2022
um on the more technical side i think
explainability like this is the problem
especially like as we start dealing with
this big data sort of purge
or like this ability to mine big data
for like a better term
like it's always nice to see a time
series of some input but the reality is
the end user typically
won't take that as gospel right
so
trying to kind of explain why and
especially with the subjectivity part of
it like
you know
we have folks who have an opinion about
a particular market and other folks who
have a diff completely counter opinion
about the market yet you're trying to
set something that works for both
um
i think trying to be very transparent
and
sort of unbiased is important and that's
where the model explanation comes into
play
um
at least so long as both sides
understand where you're coming from it's
defendable
um then you don't run into this sort of
problem but that is sort of evolving i
like in finance and like financial
engineering i mean you can tell like
there is some form of absoluteness to
the values that you produce right like a
lot of structural models a lot of
implied implicit assumptions
uh
so there is you know somebody wins
somebody loses right
in some of this sort of weak predictor
area there isn't that
the only thing you can kind of tell is
that
i've looked at something and
this is how it works and this is why i
put it at that level
um i think that piece people forget
about like especially sentiment analysis
they think there's some absolute measure
but really it really really depends i
think the question there's no such thing
as a better model it's more like what's
the context and is it self-consistent
right those are the two two things that
you want to keep in mind
um
i think it's it's interesting how
i mean the first one you mentioned was
around hiring
but i i see so many different
jobs out there on on linkedin and i try
to share as many as i i can and then i
also see so many people who are looking
for jobs right now as well and it
it feels like there's some like mismatch
happening there and
um
i know ian you
you can speak to this a little bit as
well but i'm just curious to
like chat a bit more about that like
what is what is going on
there and why is it such a challenge
you know i think it depends on what
you're looking for right like that
that's part of it
i mean on both sides the applicant and
the
basically the company is higher the
hiring company
[Music]
i think some of the applicants i mean
smp is a pretty big company they just
don't want to work for the company you
know
um
so that you kind of run into that
problem
on the other side like like my the teams
that i deal with they have to be
like basically have i think they need to
know both r and python
well enough to at least
articulate
um at least to use
to use them uh for
for basically
uh explorative data analysis and r and
python a little bit of basically
distributed distributed programming
and that's very rare
um i think generally people gravitate
out of grad school they tend to
gravitate to one or the other and then
it's like hard to kind of switch that
mentality i think that's the
i think those at least in my experience
i think those are the two major
roadblocks to that sort of mismatch
frank i see that you're unmuted and i'm
going to take that as a hand race
uh
would you agree with it with everything
you just said right that division that
our python's played no you use you you
know both you can talk to both because
you'll need different tools for
different projects
and then ultimately i'm just wondering
who on your team is
is thriving right what makes a team
member because you're talking about all
these different projects that you're
doing in sort of different ways it feels
like your work isn't as streamlined as
probably we all want it to be at this
point right it's evolving it's
developing
can you describe some of the folks in
your team that are just phenomenal and
doing really well in that yeah
no no i hear you yeah i think a lot of
it is like for again like um the ones
that are thriving i mean they come in
with a pretty strong technical
background both in math and and
programming right
so the ones that kind of move up
faster are the ones that understand what
you're trying to do with it more
because as you can imagine we're you
know in some days you're working on some
you know sustainable
development goal thing another day
you're working on some sentiment
analysis and another day you're working
structural model so the ones that
actually get what you're trying to do we
put we put them in front of clients and
they thrive
by by becoming a bit again a lot more
product management
they're able to explain it as well as a
product manager
and
but they also of course have that
technical background so those are the
ones that move up then the second side
of it is the management piece so because
we're my team is relatively small we
rely on some of the it forks we rely on
the
content like what we call contents like
data acquisition
and those are all technical folks so
being able to sort of manage those sort
of dotted line teams
and still meet your deadlines with that
slippage
those two things kind of
move somebody up on the
scale um
on the exploratory data analysis side
like we do have some more
like i would say creative topics uh that
come on where we don't know if there is
a product but we bought the data anyway
you know
um so we have folks who
who kind of thrive on
trying like multiple different types of
models to see if they can actually mine
it for something useful
um but
that
that in conjunction with basically the
understanding of the use case is sort of
important so those that's the other side
of it
do you ever sacrifice so when you when
you say that they're more technical my
mind immediately goes to phd in math or
phd in finance or something or like phd
in physics right something like that
um do you ever ever sacrifice on that
end of the let's say academic spectrum
right if you can find people who know
the
like the technical acumen are python
right they can they can do the analysis
there um and they're also like very
keyed into the business
so they can do that communication piece
very fluidly um
do you
do yeah yeah like typically i would do
grad school above i don't really
specifically look for phds uh not in a
bad way it's just um you know it depends
what they want to do and then finance
too they in finance the banks typically
have a lot more
uh which we call like more structured
paths for the phd side of it and the
quant development side and and some
folks just want to do that um
again we're like we're more like a
fintech than a finn
attack
you know so like that there's not
necessarily as rejuved a path as the
banks right um for sort of that track
but yeah i mean
ability to learn quickly i mean
you know the
languages change
you know
the business changes
being able to adapt is more important to
me than basically um
you know i mean obviously there's a bare
minimum right but
between that and just like pure
technical
i'd rather have someone who can adapt to
be honest yeah
as a follow-up to that
um and some of the non-technical skills
i see millie asked a question about that
millie if you feel comfortable jumping
in and introducing yourself would you
want to ask that question
i can also ask too um but it says what
are the non-technical skills and values
that you have when looking for data
scientists
non-technical yeah like so a lot of it
is more
like presentation skills right
being a little you know um articulate
like succinct right write some writing
skills like we do a lot of thought
leadership and things like that so just
trying to sort of
um again do like i used to be called
techno marketing but white papers you
know some form of
uh white paper type things so there's a
there's that level that you want to have
um
i mean honestly not all of it comes like
out of school you're not going to have
all that so typically we end up
bringing the junior person on calls
mute just shadowing to see how that
articulation and lately i've been
putting folks more on internal calls
with
like
kind of pure business side folk uh
business side colleagues
and can i where basically if they make a
mistake or say something kind of funny
but it's not you know
there's no real problem eventually they
kind of graduate up to like a client
call right
um
yeah i again i don't expect people
like at least i don't really if you were
working other firms i do kind of expect
some level there but if you're coming
out of like grad school i wouldn't
necessarily not
super worried about it so long as you
can kind of adapt
a lot of listening actually is more
um
you you rarely jump on a call where
everybody's just glowingly happy on a
cliff you know
it's very rare
[Laughter]
i'm sure you our studio you guys are
used to that i've been on the other side
sure
and um i guess before like jumping off
this this topic of hiring too i i know
ian we were chatting a little bit about
like how a lot of job descriptions are
are written poorly in some cases and
i think i've also just like started to
see
um
well what is interesting to me is i
started to see different job postings
that say like shiny in the title are
like tidy models engineered to to get
people interested and um
was curious seeing if you could jump in
and speak to that a little bit too
sure yeah and that's something i
encountered a lot um
[Music]
recently being promoted into a
leadership role for clinical data
science what we do in clinical data
science is pretty specific actually
and so
going across different job ads job
boards
seeing different job postings there's
always some disconnect between the data
science hiring manager and the
recruiting partner
as well as how the job ad is written
and so um
you know
one good example brought up earlier
today and brought up in earlier sessions
like with julia and then with john
thompson a couple weeks ago
was um you know and just mentioned
earlier the idea of python and r
together interoperability and um
uh
that not being stressed enough
in the job ad um
would get past the recruiter into the
data science hiring manager and you know
they really just want python but they
had r just as prominent
in the job description with python but
as a primary r programmer that i am
primarily what we use in on the clinical
side
um
that now you know we've wasted a
recruiting interview and a hiring
manager interview and something that
could have been weeded out through the
job description alone
um
and that's just my take on it but that
was a really reoccurring thing and it
doesn't have to always be i thought
python versus r it could have been
you know they really want someone that
is highly skilled in reinforcement
learning
only or
primarily whereas you know i stay and to
supervise and unsupervised learning
mainly with the clinical stuff so it was
those kinds of things that i ran into
was it more so
um
that the recruiter was then um
kind of weeding out for that which
wasn't in the job posting or once you
actually were talking to right well
that's hard to tell
um and it's different um
different for every job once you
sometimes you don't get to the hiring
manager you you're with a technical
recruiter um you know you obviously want
to be honest and communicate what your
skills are
um
and you say you know really i'm a
primary i'm an r programmer and i use it
for
um like midi said i use it for
stats i'm not big on the data
engineering data architecture side um
being open and communicating about that
with recruiter is great and you should
do that but that doesn't mean the
recruiter necessarily knows
how that does not translate to what the
data science hiring manager is looking
for
how does that
work in your team moody
yeah i was just thinking through it it's
not really very pretty either
yeah i mean
we i mean i don't have a solution and we
try to do the same we have the same
problem like we end up on the recruiter
has a sort of an hr type of call
but by the time the resume hits it's
basically almost a buzzword match of
what you have
and then basically they offload it to a
first line of defense which is like some
person my team and would basically have
an interview and then that then we ask
the questions that you were asking the
beginning to try to fish out if where
the applicant stands
and then if if they graduate from that
then they go into the sort of second
round and third round um
yeah i don't like its stuff right like
especially in like my area because like
well i mean i guess a clinical is pretty
technical too
like you know sometimes i don't know how
to articulate it myself on a
like so you're either like i try to what
i try to do is reach out to like the
network like obviously folks in our
studio folks around that i know
and try to say hey because they're more
than likely we'll have applicants that
at least understand the domain
uh so it makes it a bit easier to kind
of weed it out but just just generally
posting
it's just basically unfortunately brute
force you just go through it and
and it's i don't really blame the
applicant or the recruiter i don't
expect the recruiter to know it as well
as you and for example right and sorry
and the applicant is also kind of
in
the state it's a it's a numbers game
right like um
you know so
they will
try to
add more things to the resume
just to kind of get that
first round so
um
yeah it's tough um
i think conferences when they were more
in person
uh events those sort of things were a
good way to recruit right um so
yeah
i think we we talked so much about some
of the non-technical skills that
we all look for and
then we talk about how people can't get
past the first stage just because of a
resume or recruiter
like
pushing down a
an applicant but
i'm just wondering like how what's the
best way to
communicate those non-technical skills
then to get to that
next stage and i think christian what
that comment you made was is really
important here too where you're saying
maybe
you said you should think anyone that
was smart enough to learn the math side
of machine learning
the business side would be easy for them
but that's not always the case
how do people
show that as they're applying
i want to jump back in again like the
point that john thompson made a couple
weeks ago about his team
um was the idea of and this these are
kind of short shortening his words you
know he was giving this idea of we have
great data scientists that do
really great at tuning hyper parameters
but we have other data scientists that
are really great at eda and doing the
program management side
and so that idea of taking the project
from start to finish as a team model
versus that idea of people jump in at
different areas i think is also worth
part of this discussion about recruiting
because
am i recruiting someone to take a
project from beginning to end
or am i recruiting someone who
is really great at turning hyper
parameters and all of those other
different disparate parts of data
science but it's not so good at the
program management side
do you see the differentiation i'm
making
so you know he was talking about that
and that really struck a chord with me
because that was
um
i think an essential part of how you
would hire
um and something you would communicate
as a data science manager to a recruiter
you know i'm looking for this data
scientist that can take it from end to
end or no these are kind of these
different areas that we would look for
primarily but if they have the rest of
it that's great
i i
uh 100 agree i tend to look at my hiring
as how do i get people to complement one
another and that i feel can
absorb that information from other
individuals to try and create a little
bit of a
a network in a way because i it's very
very hard when you're looking for
someone that has like very specific
skill set let's say in healthcare and r
and python and whatever
but i can find
like slices of that and then try to
assemble those slices in a manner that's
going to like punch above its weight
class so to say rather than like have
like you know try to find the person
that fit that's that's my opinion but i
totally agree with that
um
how do you guys explain that to your
stakeholders you have five
data scientists on your team the
stakeholders want 15 different things
you have five people and they say you're
only going to work on two things because
you can do two things really well
because you have that compliment of the
people on your team right we can do two
things in the next two months and then
we'll do another two things but they're
like no no right now you should be
working on all of these right and i feel
like that's such a hairy conversation
every time i step into it any any advice
there from anybody yeah it's like it's
like for me like for a while like
they would describe my role as stuff and
things so you know
um
no i mean like
yeah so like what i do at least i i tied
to the business so we're like hey look
there's this you know i'm a bit of a
luxury now uh because i have like
basically three four products that are
making revenue
uh
so i just say hey we need to augment
so-and-so to support at least one of
those two products one of those four
products or and do eda and take
something end-to-end i tend to get more
end-to-end just because i'm on
relatively at least early on i'm on much
tighter time frames and then we have
folks who are more senior that they can
go into hyper parameter tuning like
check basically the other person's work
um
[Music]
but
yeah the stakeholders i keep trying to
tie to a business
need like a a revenue generating need i
mean also partially because my side of
business is revenue generating right
um
i haven't had much success in like pure
like
you know
like saying i need somebody just to
think through stuff right
uh i mean as important as that is i have
senior folks on the team who just do
that right and they write
but the stakeholders generally not
you know don't don't want to hire like
they don't want to pay for someone
just to sort of do research right
um so that's kind of how i work around
it
i don't want to jump in too soon and and
switch gears
and if someone else has something to add
there
i guess just to uh answer frank's
question i think i mean in my particular
situation
we do have a lot of things going on but
the
you know healthcare and our particular
real world data space it's kind of
difficult to find people that are like
cancer experience and like our
experience and epidemiology experience
so it's like these are like unicorns if
you find someone like that and uh
someone probably also already has an
offer out for him um
so we have to kind of augment otherwise
we're gonna sit spinning our wheels for
six months and you're never gonna get
anything done right so
i think in our case it's it's a
relatively easy sell to be like look
we're assembling the team to be able to
deliver on on a variety of these
projects and
generally i think in at least my
industry it's kind of understood like
we can't have someone that does
and do everything so
yeah a data analyst is not
like every single data analyst isn't the
same or every single day isn't the same
yeah
and that's the tough part the
stakeholders don't understand that
necessarily like it's they're usually on
the business like they're much more
senior like peer management like you
know upper management
so you gotta like for me i i learned the
hard way you gotta tie it to
you know x percent is
a tied to revenue generating why percent
is tied to sort of
you know r d and you know that percent
is stacked to something else like
you kind of play a bit around that and
then you get like basically someone says
okay sure that makes sense for you know
but if you just say hey i just need
someone to do research or
you know or
just to do some full data or things like
that you know like it's not gonna at
least my site doesn't work
maybe shifting gears a little bit i see
there are a few questions from earlier
that
we hadn't covered yet and christian
yours was about um kind of selling
the value of of data science internally
i'm wondering if you want to um
you know expand a bit on that question
i can
i can read it out um
no um
that was
it wasn't really a question for the
group right that was just more of like
so there's like the aws like
managed instances you can set up for
rstudio you can have it just like
pre-packaged to hit run those exist for
our studio enterprise but there's
nothing for like the free version of our
studio if i wanted to quickly spin
something up and be like hey look at all
these cool things and then take that to
my management team i can't do that
because there's not that free version i
don't have
three days to get uh an instant spun up
myself at the when i could just do it at
the click of a button so if there was a
free version
i could use to pitch to other people
that would be awesome
i can actually answer that one
um
so
there actually is something that you
could use and i don't want to make this
call
sale together at all but there's a
hosted evaluation instance that you
could try out and i know for some reason
that's been really useful for
just like bringing the examples to like
their meeting and saying like look this
is the shiny app i made here's this
jupiter notebook i published or
um
so i can i can send that to
christian um and if anybody else ever
needs that you can let me know i can
always connect you with the right person
too
um
but
but moody did you
have to do any of that internally kind
of like
selling the value of data science or was
it already
there and understood by the teams that
you work with
yeah i mean
yeah no i had to do a lot of selling
like both on the language and the value
proposition i mean it was funny because
they like
like um
yeah data science as a term and like we
created teams after that that also came
from another acquisition we have so they
kind of there was a bigger top-down sort
of initiative to scale up
like i said i technically i'm not data
science and smp i'm product management
but i happen to have data scientists
report to me right so
but yeah selling the
value proposition
there was a little
tricky and i think it's still tricky
because some of it some of the more
um like you end up basically trying
multiple things and failing sometimes
and the business doesn't always like
that right they they want you to
they want they want to buy data
do something with it and then make money
off it that's basically what we do right
and basically buying data and then
finding out it doesn't work is usually
like
like you must have done something wrong
right
so
i think that's part of the i mean i have
less of a problem doing that i mean
early on what we've done what i did was
you know
we actually presented to a pretty high
up on the food chain
uh i still remember
like our markdowns uh when they first
kind of came out
and um we were lucky that our ceo at the
time was uh he's still there like s p
global doug peterson basically he
basically
was a analyst at city back in the day
and so he
looked at them this sort of sort of
almost financial research report
and it was very interesting to him i was
like oh wow i can do this now like you
don't have to you can actually pull the
data
do the model do it all on markdown and
have the analysis all written in one
simple thing and i was like
i'm not saying that sold everything but
at least sold my team
um so i mean it's a little harder now
because like folks are their threshold
has gone up i think a lot more because
they've seen
um
but i mean my suggestion just
like selling to the business is always
more like or the value proposition of
data science is again like
the out don't don't just
throw like 10 different r d efforts out
there pick the one or two that actually
succeed and then for those ones sort of
do
like what i do with the incubator like
build a shiny app and do it the way you
think a client would do it and then show
that
uh because that sells it more than just
saying i can do you know i know
you know super basically technical
jargon right
um
that doesn't help anybody
that's a great point
and i see you unmuted so i take that
yeah
well you know and moody was speaking to
revenue generation and part of what my
team does and my experience is actually
cost avoidance as well as clinical
outcomes and so
the way i try to do the value
proposition to leadership and the way
when i've been under
higher data science leadership than
previous positions is a simple
calculation of what's called blue
dollars
um in cost avoidance where we really
just try to keep a high level of where
to go in we can do an internal consult
for a team if we can do this consult and
save fte hours we're gonna you know
we're gonna uh collect those blue
dollars and present them quarterly
saying you know we saved this many fte
hours
by
overhauling a process
um
avoiding cost getting better clinical
outcomes so that's kind of a
summary on how i do it on my end just a
little bit different
of an approach
yeah we have that in the content team
and the other data that's exactly what
we do efficiencies and yeah i mean i
don't do it but like another my
colleague
he runs exactly that that makes sense
yeah cost savings yeah
moody what has been one of your money
your most unique problems across most
industries that you've solved with data
science
there's an anonymous question that came
in there
most unique problems
i would say the china sentiment
i really knew nothing about basically
china like as a
you know beyond the news and stuff right
and that was like took about three four
years to get to the point we're at now
and that like and the funny thing is
none of my team members spoke chinese so
and we had to basically
build something using the
20 000 or so companies and the amazing
thing is there is a lot of data that
they collect and because we're smp we
can access that data and in some cases a
lot of it is public domain
but actually trying to sort of
understand that business and that
context and then make it easy for the
rest of the world to sort of have some
sort of window into that
that area especially when i really
didn't know as much or anything really
um that was quite it's very agitating
right and then
we hired obviously labelers we had some
folks who are in in china who specialize
in that market help us so
that was very very unique than what i'm
kind of used to doing right
kevin i'm seeing now that that was your
question but it was coming through as
anonymous so feel free to jump in if you
wanted to add anything there as well
uh
yeah i i'm i'm glad i got the um the
chance to hear the answer to that
question um
yeah i always hear um
very
like industry specific
um
results on that question on which is the
most unique and
it's a nice perspective that you just
gave yeah basically like if you
generalize it it's just that situations
that are very interesting that happens
to be the most idiosyncratic one i think
i've done in about
like the last 10 years or so right like
um you actually have no idea so there's
other things that are
more like just
problems that are more like big data
problems like i'm working on something
on transactional data with credit card
payments i just like terabytes of
information that
and then that also presents its
difficulties right
um
[Music]
but yeah like something complex again it
a lot of it was spent understanding what
we were trying to do
[Music]
and for whom
and then from that point on it became
kind of almost a linear
set of instructions to basically execute
at least like almost a decision tree so
you can exclude certain options and i
learned the hard way the you see a lot
of like those pre-packaged nlp tools out
there they
they are not really
they're mostly on the sort of the
english latin sort of side of it
like that area there isn't really
anything that we use fast techs for
example and that was really bad actually
for finance for finance and something
like chinese
because they're trained on a lot of
wikipedia data
and when you start putting in the
language plus the context
they kind of fall apart so if you're
just doing something that's sort of
generic hello you know kind of nlp type
of problem
it's fine right but once you start
actually trying to use it to do
something more
specific it falls apart and then we had
to do our own basic vectorization for it
i see another um question from earlier
around
this project ingestion process you have
and
um it's quite a longer question or whole
so i might have you
explain it if that's okay
uh yeah sure um
the question is really on how you um
how you deal with project ingestion
right we as xero science means we get
multiple requests for projects
um
and they're
all of them are urgent for the business
um and when we get into it
that's when we find out that the data
needed to make the decisions is either
completely missing or partially missing
or not enough to make the decisions uh
but that's only several sometimes
several months in right where our data
scientists are spinning their wheels
trying to like you know put things
together this thing in a postgres
database here there's an api there
there's like pdfs you've got pdf
sometimes that we have to scrape
and
um it gets frustrating because a lot of
data scientists really want to focus on
the modeling aspect and we all recognize
that you know is that 80 20 you spend 80
percent of your time on the data however
there has to be the balance where
if that's all we are doing and we you
know all the data scientists are very
capable right so just because you can do
the data cleanup and you know data
munching that's not your primary role
right so then you know folks do get like
burn out
um
and so we are trying to develop
a better ingestion process for how do
you accept
projects and how do you evaluate
data readiness before we engage the data
scientists and launch it formally as a
data science project and i was wondering
do you guys have any thoughts around
that or any existing processes you
follow
i'd be interested to hear
yeah so like yeah like like again
because i'm running a small team my
opportunity cost of someone failing
not because of them but the data was
actually high
um
so i don't have a like a bulletproof way
to sort of prioritize projects i mean
generally speaking we try to look at
revenue potential
is the data completely new
or is it something that is new and
is it new and can be linked to something
we already have
generally if you get something that's
sort of
independent from the rest of the
database your like your value
proposition is going to be
much harder
but if it's something that is related to
some of the companies we cover today and
they have other measures
then there's a higher
success chances
um but yeah it's happened to me where
you basically work on something for like
six months plus and then you end up with
like well i guess it didn't work you
know
it's unfortunate but i mean
it kind of comes back to the business
side because you kind of try to
whoever's adding this project you try to
do your best just have them explain
in very simple terms
what they want out of it
right and and that's where i kind of use
that sometimes when things kind of fall
apart they're not very well defined then
it's like well
we really didn't know
so we tried and it took a while because
of these complexities and
at least we found out that why we failed
so that's not really an opportunity
anymore so that way you kind of dance a
bit around the
[Music]
issue
right yeah it happens it happens a lot
um
but yeah i said i also thread the work
through other teams so depending on like
sort of lower value things i kind of
give to other folks see kind of monitor
it so you try to kind of
you again at the end of the day you want
to really support the business line and
then they're bringing it to you not
because it's just kind of a nice to have
there's some reason behind it
uh
so it's good to sort of try to support
them
as much as you can and bernard i just
put a lot of folks on like at any point
in time any member is working on at
least a project and a half
or maybe two
so like you know they're taking one end
to end and then the other whatever
residual is we're supporting someone
else on my team so that they don't get
burnt out
too much right you know
in in supporting oh sorry hole you go
no just saying thank you and i have a
follow-up whenever you're ready rachel
feel free to ask it
um
the other question i have is is um
[Music]
we sometimes are following
victims to our own like success and
capability because the initial phases of
a project are often very descriptive in
nature right we have like we deal with a
lot of engineering data that engineers
are not looking at
right so to build you know we focus on
forecasting models and getting those
insights but the very first part is just
all the descriptive analytics that has
to happen and then you know we then end
up creating dashboards and show them
that hey this is your data these are you
know like the visual insights before we
even touch the modeling
which
uh they love
uh but then we also end up
like having to maintain those long term
and we you know end up being becoming
like dashboard maintainers right
which i see the value in it but
it's you know making a one-time
dashboard to show insights and then
focus on the modeling is very different
from now maintaining a production grade
dashboard right that if anything goes
down or the upstream data changes
slightly suddenly like this you know you
you know drop everything and fix it
because there's so many people looking
at it uh
how do you face similar issues and do
you have or do you have teams that like
take over dashboards and now they've you
know that's their job is to just
maintain these production
widgets
yeah no yeah that's uh
that's why it's like yeah no yeah so so
like so so
like i try to and then this is
happened over time
so it wasn't like
i didn't really think about it and then
structured it just
fell into problems and then tried to
address it like the client-facing part
the incubator i own so that i'm kind of
tied to so you know so i don't like we
try to write it we have some
i.t folks sort of help but
we kind of now the internal stuff
generally speaking once there's some
success and there's no way to like there
has to be a way to production
i turn it over to
the
like our tech team obviously
with the product with the segments
product manager and then they work
together to get it done
uh and then i shut down basically the
old app like it has a lifetime so i
don't i'm exactly not on the hook
basically keep maintaining it
um
yeah and sometimes like what what's more
like so in my world it's like i'm kind
of a bit faster than the
general data science team and the data
science team is
a little bit uh faster than the tech
team and the tech team is more like
business as usual features
so what i've basically been kind of
struggling is more transitioning to the
technology folks
in on things so you know you do two
three releases of something in
production because we wrote some service
endpoint that's
basically supporting it and it just
happens that the software engineers
don't necessarily have the same
background
and i'm talking programming background
not math
um
right
and that's kind of where
i'm kind of focused on now is getting
that team up to speed so that they can
actually not involve my team in future
enhancements
um
but yeah i mean
you know
like what i end up doing is kind of just
allocating
folks directly to them and saying you're
owning it now after this release so you
have to sort of we'll here to you know
you have to shadow
get your hands dirty and then basically
take it over eventually and and anything
that that has a path to production
that's already refined i've gotten the
feedback i shut down basically
you know
how do you handle that that hand off
then and getting all the teams on the
same page yeah so i mean it's obviously
i have a counterpart in the software
engineering team right and
there we agree that that's the right
thing to do and then it's more like how
many releases does it take on if we need
to resource the software engineering
team on our end
so we do like the first like obviously
like it's almost like like the first
time it's like
you know 75 25 75 my team 25 software
engineering eventually is 50 50 and then
25.75 basically two to three releases
um
even that's a little slow for my taste
but like you know
uh but i mean it's it's just the the
like
like a lot of the
more
like programming language
dotnet js javascript folks right
um
java they're they're just not aware of
like r and python so it's more of that
side of it
than it is like again it's not like the
models we end up owning anyway there's
no way around that right but like
um
but i think it's more like a skill set
mismatch right
um
but
yeah
thinking of those those initial
deployments to or where you're maybe
presenting something to the executive
team
what's something that your team has
worked on that really impressed the
executive team and and delivered a ton
of value
the the we have that the financial
extraction tool i was talking about in
the beginning where basically you take
an unstructured pdf
of a small business or a private
business and you upload it into our
system it's like literally sitting like
you just got it from an email or someone
else
and then in a few minutes you click
through a few points in the desktop and
then all of a sudden that data that you
care about those financial line items
across the balance sheet income cash
flow are already in our platform
with assignment with the mnemonics like
with with the metrics that we create
our company hierarchy our taxonomy in
like a few minutes that's rare right
that really resonates a lot with
basically
the
the business um and and that's like kind
of an ongoing sort of product that we're
we're
we're expanding further and further into
um
it's a very simple message right like
you've got something that came from
someone else and then all of a sudden it
looks like it's in your desktop
we have we do this in a systematic
fashion for our public company data
fundamentals data right that's like
lots of teams validating checking
nlp sort of extracting and all that
right but it's not like
in a way it's organized there's a much
more rigid pipeline here you're talking
about something you know you just
emailed me and i can just upload it as
long as it's a financial statement so
that that message is simple to
understand that resonates
and
and i'm i'm sure other people might
understand from this but what what
exactly is that deliverable deliverable
is it like a shiny application or
somebody well the prototype wasn't shiny
like you connect back but now it's in
our desktop platform so yeah you're
getting basically like a
financial statement of a small business
and then you're taking out like total
revenue net income ebitda
like all the measures that you care
about but you don't actually have to
highlight or do anything
you just upload a document and it'll
extract out the line items and then
takes those one items and assigns them
to our like taxonomy
which is an smp you know over
decades has been building this taxonomy
and so in a few clicks you're basically
take something that never resided in our
platform and all of a sudden it looks
like it's part of our platform
and and then you can basically then you
can do credit scoring so after that you
have those numbers you can save and
archive that information
you can do credit scoring around it you
can do
you know a lot of other opera build a
lot more ratios around it so it becomes
as though it's a company that we've
ingested normally
uh but the user is completely user
driven like we don't touch it we don't
even know what the document is or who
the company is it's proprietary yeah
oh wow and i know an hour goes by really
quickly and we're already at the the top
of the hour so i know some people have
to to jump off and
moody if you have to jump off
let me know but i'd love to stay on and
ask a few remaining questions if that's
okay
um but for anyone that has to leave
moody what's the best way to get in
contact with you if people have
follow-up questions is it linkedin
yeah linkedin or um probably linkedin is
the easiest i can track it better than
my day-to-day email yeah linkedin is
good
perfect you know yeah rachel maybe i can
send you some some of the folks we're
hiring and then you can share it with
the folks like the
the the the people
yeah everybody on the data science
hanging out like definitely some urls
yeah yeah cool yeah yeah send them to me
and i'll put them up on linkedin as well
um
i do see there's a another question
um that frank had around
a podcast you said it comes from a
podcast that you've been watching frank
or listening to frank are you still on
yeah i didn't want to take credit i
think it's a great question
um it's sad moody it sounds like a lot
of the
the work that you and your team does
comes from stakeholders so i'm curious
on the flip side of that if you had
unlimited resources what is the problem
that you would try to tackle
unlimited and nobody's asked me that
it's
[Laughter]
so freeing
[Laughter]
that's true yeah that's a good question
actually
uh yeah
i think there's a like like smp
like we
i'd love to basically dig into our full
data repository and identify what can be
linked efficiently to kind of target
like we have so much data that we don't
mind like the china sentiment data for
example that was
somebody else bought that a long time
ago as part of something
and it was just sitting there on a
folder so i would love to sort of do
more projects like that where i would
look through our full repository
and
see what we actually house today without
needing to acquire
additional data sets and then seeing if
we can kind of combine what we have
today to something more useful um do you
think that that sounds like a
s p global data knowledge
database or knowledge graph yeah so we
have data lakes like we have a lot of
data lakes law data warehouses we have a
basically
structural way of like keeping track of
it the problem is it loses that business
context right so it becomes kind of one
segment buys the data it gets linked and
then that segment uses it and then you
forget about it
and it just sits there and there are
obviously technology people and data
people supporting it i mean yeah like so
i would just kind of go on a fishing
expedition basically go through it and
just see
what can come out of it because i would
hazard the guests we're sitting on a lot
of things that that probably cost us
money to maintain and we just probably
use a fraction of its value
you know
um
but i mean that's the nature of the
business right like you know being kind
of like a business
you're always interested in the new data
you just bought and how it links to it
and then eventually the new data becomes
all data and so you forget about it you
move on
so
i think that would be it yeah
frank's question made me think to ask
this as well moody are there other
podcasts or resources that you
listen to or read that you'd recommend
to others
not podcasts but like yeah i mean i read
a lot of the our studio post like
jonathan regenstein's posts on linkedin
right like matt dan shows a lot of that
work like
um
you know beyond like the usual like wall
street journal kind of stuff um
podcasts i haven't really been kind of
following up too much be honest
thank you
trevor i i see your question from
earlier as well and that see that you're
still on would you want to ask that
question live and introduce yourself
yeah hi hi everyone hi again so i'm
trevor thompson
i always always try my best to make a
meeting
so i'm actually a research manager
in jamaica igt it's a global corporation
we have a big operation in the u.s also
in italy
we're in over 100 countries right so i
do research it's a gaming company
um we provide support for
larger companies around the world both
technology
and also marketing
right
so we do a lot of research
they what i wanted to know
moody
um because you're you're kind of unique
where your product seems to be a
software you know i was just trying to
to to see
how the approach that you take to to
developing applications because
um
as data people
beat analysts or scientists
i'm always curious about the process
that we use to to come up with with
applications it could be a shiny
application but what process do we think
about when we're going through do we
have
systematic way of developing what we do
or
do we do it
um in an unstructured way
that's a question yeah so like yeah
typically like we'll have like
like some idea that there was a customer
problem that's being faced and then it's
like okay so
we we take that
idea refine it into some form of at
least a easy to understand simple
language business problem
what are we targeting to solve then
we go back and hunt to see if we have
data that can solve that problem and if
we do we build a like a mini prototype
around it
right and that involves basically that
includes the model
and then we push out something kind of
rudimentary to begin with at least for
internal folks to understand what the
prototype looks like
refine that over some time and then push
like graduate that prototype into
something that external that folks can
use
get their feedback
and then once and that that can be done
in shiny right and um
and get their feedback and then
eventually you've reached some happy
medium and that's what you end up
basically building as requirements for
the technology folks to build in our
platform so that's
generally the process flow like
end-to-end
um
so yeah you basically try something
first
and then you kind of show it to whoever
asks you
okay
yeah
okay so you do approve the type okay
yeah chinese is really good for that
like if you can so so long as you can
you have an idea of what the requirement
is typically you'll
you'll build a model and then build it
in shiny and then show them something
quick even on my desktop i don't need to
use like the bigger thing it's something
simple yeah and then
at least that's sort of your first
litmus test yeah
oh so it sounds as if you're using
something like
loosely speaking agile
technique because you i guess you have
different iterations do
you um so you develop a prototype you
get feedback then you make adjustments
and the cycle continues
yeah it's not a waterfall approach right
there is like a more agile safe approach
right and then but the technology team
are much more
uh on that safe
safe agile sort of approach than than i
am but we try to follow solar the same
methodology a lot of a lot of small
iterations right
okay
understand thank you
ben i i see that you unmuted do you have
anything to add there too
if or feel free to put in the chat too
moody there's just a few more remaining
questions that i see coming in on on
slido
um and one is are you able to estimate
the roi from using open source languages
if yes do you have a clear business
example of use cases where you saved
money by using them
on using open source languages
right yes
so like our python that's that level
or like libraries
i know we couldn't assume but i'm going
to assume that yes
no it's funny note i i i get it like um
like languages you yeah so
i had like nobody asked me that so like
but a few years back i had a question
kind of similar to that
for internal purposes and what it wasn't
even my idea actually someone else like
what we did to measure what what he did
to measure it was to use lines of code
so if you had written something in c
plus plus versus say r
um how many lines of code less lines i
could you did in r versus say c
right
and that kind of gives you an idea about
your efficiency as a programmer right
and then that kind of
takes over also the library part because
in r you're still probably writing using
some you know some other libraries to
contlib or something like that right
so that that usually that measure kind
of shows the value proposition
um now how you tied to revenue that's a
different story was more time saving
than just revenue
um
but yeah no not like
i mean you have that matlab versus like
our python kind of question around i
suppose that's but that's
i don't know
we have folks who use matlab and you
know i use matlab back in the day right
like
there's nothing wrong with it i i
just you know there's room for i think a
lot of different languages depending on
the application so
you know
it sounds like a lot of the
value that you've shown has come from
the data products that you've built with
images or
yeah just generally like wouldn't i mean
don't go crazy right like you know
[Laughter]
you know like you know julia you've got
like a lot of other stuff right uh out
there uh i i'm sure they will have some
applications down the line but
but yeah like at least like our python
has kind of become much more business as
usual i mean a few years back r wasn't a
few years like you know more than five
years ago right like
um but i think it's much more accepting
now right so
but yeah because you're you know again
you're it's your like your maintenance
overhead can go up so you might
you know you have to there's some
like
intuition you should have right because
if someone like i hire somebody who
knows
julia really well and then builds some
amazing application and quits
and then i've got nobody left right um
so you have to have that sort of there
are checks and balances around what
language you use you shouldn't just let
everybody do
but
and taking that a little bit further i
see there's a question around the tech
stack that your team uses to do this
work
and maybe i'm combining two questions
here but also thinking about that tech
stack and working with certain clients
do you
bill back
to like certain groups within the
company um
yeah yeah we could work closely with the
data science team
uh who are under technology so that like
that's very helpful because we again
kind of have that checks and balances
around um
[Music]
like tech stack i mean we use r and
python quite a bit right um
i think more like radius mongodb
depending on the situation like
um obviously a lot of our internal we
have a vpc in aws so a lot of sort of
cloud devops that knowledge there spark
for distributed programming
um trying to think what else like a
sequel like a lot of sequel depending on
snowflake we've been using snowflake
quite a bit like we've been
um
but we still do a lot of relational
stuff like we have oracle and sql server
so a lot of like knowledge around
pulling the data and how how to sort of
do it um
databricks we've been had a lot of
success in using databricks as a
platform for production pipelines
um
i think that's pretty much
it i would say
thank you moody i'm checking to see if
there are any questions that i miss and
i
am not seeing any but i want to do a
quick check to rob and rob who've been
helping monitor as well
one um
one final question that i always like to
ask and
um
i think that a lot of people on the call
may also be in this position but as
aspiring data science leaders what
advice would you give to someone
for maybe
getting to that that leadership role
yeah i mean we kind of hit on it right
earlier but like yeah i mean it really
understand the context that you're
trying to solve for right like i mean
obviously there's some level of
technical capabilities you need to have
right
both in math statistics and programming
but after that to move up you really
need to understand what the business use
case that you're trying to solve for is
in in very simple terms
um right and and
and that's that's i think what makes it
sort of a quant versus sort of a leader
right is the understanding that context
and and
um
you know
and you should question your own numbers
a lot right like there were some a lot
of times like it's like oh look look at
the correlations i'm like this it's
great um
but if you see something that doesn't
look like the norm question why and then
dig into it and you should be ready to
explain why
it's not like the norm i care more about
those outliers
um
than than otherwise so like it really is
kind of question your your numbers and
then understand the context that you're
applying it to
awesome well thank you so much moody for
joining us and and thank you for
kind of running over with us past past
the hour i really appreciate you
sharing all your insights with everyone
and
just being so open
so thank you to everyone for joining as
well and hopefully we'll see you back
next week so same time same zoom room
thank you all have a great rest of the
day
you